how's um Rasmus welcome back to second
son we in Chinatown now BIA look at my
awesome where are you looking you're not
looking
come on you just started God you have
these neon power that should fit
Chinatown right this is Chinatown and
I'm a racist and I just wanna check all
right cool can I spin the pinecone I
don't know what I just said but I think
I meant it
let's start any mission wait what
destroyed nearby do you pity all right
let's do that
high-five don't dodge my hi-fi that's
extremely rude
can we make it no we can my run a Miguel
let's use our sword laser sword
it's a chain huh what do you know by
chains can we do it yeah yeah oh man
okay well if you want to help you can
help me find one of the escape conduits
you might be here in the district okay
you haven't know if any of these people
have actual powers oh absolutely
well thanks I'm sorry man what do you
say your name was
my mom got Delson off of an old western
you both have terrible names let's just
go with that I mean beautiful names
don't be offended um ed guy you need to
indulge lane all right and why would I
trust you random guy just calling me I
mean I trust you brothers your real fans
but and but yeah I'm thinking the
easiest thing to do here is somehow drop
the road a little you know pull the rug
out from underneath them well take the
chance that'll kill the con do what I'm
looking for I think I'm just gonna cut
the supports and the trucks will make a
drop a little BAM
it's a roadblock come on watch but you
know from a safe distance of course
because when we conduits go to work you
mortals better give us a wide berth I'll
let you know if I find anything more
about the convoy though what what were
they
number two number three and Ambika
probably shouldn't send underneath this
thing may hey what are you gonna do with
this Cowboys supposed to show up I mean
I really don't know for sure yeah still
here just been making friends with the
locals it doesn't seem to be traffic up
top man yep all done at the head topside
and get ready for a little game of
chicken with the dupes what the [ __ ] is
going on why am I doing this why don't I
make any sense
first explain thanks
I can't hear you I wish I could your
beautiful voice oh stop it is he playing
come on
damnit and that's the backup
nailed it it works the sand clan were at
five hey Eugene talk to me man hi
that helicopters full pack of them
hopefully they can see me in the fog
that's good
come on just hand over your prisoners
and we'll call it a day hey I got one I
don't know how but I did
changing this mouth maybe do it that one
my love my love my love my love love
love this die Mar all of this oh nice
why are all those bold I don't know
stain time to search
oh wait that's not searching what the
fudge
what happened amazing we're alive yeah
that guy is walking through fire cool
guys just walk through fire and then
they waved their arms like got it take
this thing up our test drive no signal
climb high BRR okay thank you need to go
this way I got something
so should prison bus can do somebody me
too sure your new alright sorry to
interrupt in the middle this is pills
from the future here to keep playing for
you you are welcome I don't know why the
[ __ ] we're going defeat there oh sorry I
don't mean to I don't mean to ignore you
guys oh man they're super powerful ow
so I guess we're gonna get the guy who
has the power to do those swords or
whatever that looks pretty awesome it
looks like a mixture of smoke and neon
or whatever growl fast are they missed
Wow oh my god they're so annoying it's
sort I'm friendly nice god they're so
annoying
oh I kill one I killed I kill - I didn't
even know how they're so annoying I'll
just use the beer rockets the Viera neon
rockets on them
there we go you dance yeah yeah yeah
they're excited god dammit you bros
would never do this would you right
they're nothing like these people right
please tell me right since this is shard
here somewhere
let's look for it really quick oh there
it is it's right there but I didn't see
it oh my god there you are
hopefully we don't get attacked we're
probably gonna get attacked but what are
you gonna do about it
hello perfect landing
I think my calculations the bus should
be around here somewhere find that last
bus or whatever did this does all right
locate their final bus for us we can do
it now that one Jesus who built these
they're terrible quality oh I need to be
evil to use that ability Oh
oh my god I got fangirls lik breaths
they're dancing for me synchronized and
yeah amazing dancing ladies thank you so
much I'll meet you back stage this guy
just likes to complain I think why set
another one you can't be me looking me
right now cuz I don't know what you're
talking about
look at this these are awful maybe it's
a sleep actually then I then I can
understand I'm not hating on who who's
ever sleep sleeping that almost rhymed
I'm a rapper okay Eric there's a guy
shooting him what I want that God give
give me now
am I gonna get angel wings cuz I will
[ __ ] my pants if that happens for us
there's so many though
who's nice and who's evil do the angels
kill him what that's the rudest thing I
ever heard in my life I'm an angel my
mom tells me every time smack my [ __ ]
up my mam that's how the song goes right
oh hello
thanks for the free smoke appreciate it
almost a friend what are they doing oh
my god I think they're dead
amazing matter they ran away
search device are you kidding me right
now so either one of those escapees can
make angels you want a high five I'm
going after God I do not like my odds in
that matchup now high five what you want
you wanted me to high-five your butt I
don't understand talk to me God's Moses
join a sniper clan five million hello
thanks for the tip so where'd you
disappear to earlier huh yeah how do you
get all this information about what's
going on sounds like helpful friends
there we are
what are we God Ready's takes one of
these things on I would want to get it
off as fast as possible because well
because there but then I guess because
they just scream attack me I'm a
suspected bioterrorist so you want
someplace private to get undressed with
a door that locks place to sit while you
changed a porta potti would be perfect
you'd kill two birds with one stone
right
bilingual bullying the hell I'm great
place to take all right well I guess we
keep looking then well drugs can't be
bad as by okay every base and varrick
Quan climbed with we're little serious
looking all the parties seriously
another pooper no can't wait to find
this guy I wish we walk in on some
random person instead why does no one
lock these in case we're trying to find
him like they're all empty but there's
so many of them yeah I'm not a freak who
goes around opening occupy porta potti
no I have better things to do oh it's
dangerous god dammit
I'm not now still here yeah about time
you made it across what's going on leave
you on your own for a couple hours and
suddenly there's angels
dive-bombing got asked something to do
with the conduit we're looking for I set
free a bunch of prisoners that dupes
were moving I think my god
well be on the lookout for anyone in a
black and yellow vest I saw one on the
ground in hang market looks like a [ __ ]
to get off blocks all over it don't
think what one cop and the family is
embarrassing enough they're fake angels
and not raw what what okay cool I'll
take it
look for more escape conduits at the
construction site okay
oh yeah
friends family escape conduits is he up
there
minecraft down to the ground where it's
safe then I'll give you a 10-second head
start mate
oh you mate what are you doing lad oh
well I could have easily catch him too
come on are ya
yeah
God ready the other one go now stop
calling me Miranda Shh whoever this
angel maker is he's pissing me off
they keep grabbing on the conduits and I
can't keep up oh if the angels aren't
bad enough there's these gangs of surly
dudes out hunting the best toys - OH
angry gang of bullies you like to cause
trouble around the International
District
you should stay clear of them so far so
good these guys are real scum of the
earth types all right I'll meet you by
the port of support you can trust me
that a lot you can trust me I'm a cop ah
okay we're at the poor deported the
party the part that yes
we're almost there be patient for
ChaCha's it's gonna be okay
brofist what I saw one shot I hate them
just fetch that's why they like deflect
my ball attention I have perfect aim
otherwise I promise
now you are stop hiding Oh what do you
think means a little bit of pain putting
on especially in there look somebody had
some Thai food chase me you want me to
chase you yeah yeah yeah chase me shoot
me shoot near me near me see what
happens when the angel shows up yeah
it's fine a really good batting average
with the Angels right now if they take
you man they take you to God knows where
I know okay but look you know how you're
always losing your phone and then you
grab mine and find it right right well
we have a GPS link so you're like a big
ugly tracking device okay right but look
we got to make this look real okay not
too real just real enough to fool the
Angels get me oh I can get you right
between yeah no no just don't be a dick
ow ow okay pretend oh it's real I
promise not Ken he's really freaking
everyone
I don't know why I'm shooting I really
don't have to do that where are you
going Reggie there you go that's how
doors work Rivest Oh
[Music]
cops were that not surprising you went
aboard with this idea oh no they got him
I could just follow him that's pretty
easy alright god first hand with an
angel that sounds
how are you okay I'll have to return
later hi guys I see him that it's far
away
McDonald's every eye are they shooting
me oh hello
I don't care my brothers in danger
there's some drainage needed to be done
i drainage I know that means either I'm
sorry okay he should be here somewhere
maybe on top of the building
hopefully yep that looks like it's it hi
friends they come out of the TVs what I
can do that too actually
so destroy the giant TVs got a like care
of them that's it
keep shooting this free never they don't
just yes
yes stop being so fluttery let me get
shot oh I'm gonna burn in hell for this
yes it's not a screen I don't understand
oh it's about to get hot in here girls
ow not my ass please please yeah that's
right keep coming up take you all down
okay whatever he says there we go did I
do oh god there's more there's blue
anymore I thought it was fine
hey that's oh my god
there we go your day
me neither I sector one of my videos oh
that's adorable
brother you make excellent live bait I
did work didn't it found the angel
conduit Slayer now we go taken out well
you come with me or what ah what I'm
gonna take this [ __ ] off
no I'm gonna go cry myself there's gotta
be a ton of weird spiky [ __ ] down there
and that brother oh yeah thanks
it was your plan and by that note we
will end this episode way alright
friends hope you enjoyed watching this
episode add a lot up on playing thanks
for hanging out with me today and thanks
for leaving a like and commenting on
this video
that's all for me now as always Shasha
browse Brophy eyes
you